if you had the opportunity would you
like to face conor mcgregor in a wwe
ring
man
i take shits bigger than that kid all
right
come on guys let's get i know you guys
all play [ __ ] video games and you're
living this [ __ ] false sense of
reality and [ __ ]
i'm 200 and [ __ ] 90 pounds all right
this guy's 145 pounds that's if he's
lucky and gets up and eats his [ __ ]
wheaties okay this is a question for
both mcgregor and cowboy i see you both
winning the championship coming up soon
could you see yourself fighting each
other coming up in the next year
yeah go ahead mcnugget you want to
answer that or no
ladies forced
[Applause]
i mean to be honest is we're difficult
doing this because i don't know who the
[ __ ] this lanky [ __ ] is
i had to google finn taylor and google
said who the [ __ ] is finn taylor
and his agent said who the [ __ ] is finn
taylor
connor do you know what wrestling here
i get i hear
your forehead
[Music]
and melissa you know who am i gonna i'm
gonna leave to melissa and for a while
we weren't even talking is that right it
was bad what was the estrangement
she thought she wasn't wanted as a child
and she thought i'd try to have an
abortion which is ridiculous and
well she was born with a coat hanging in
her ear
so
i can understand
being unknown be humble sit down you
about to get black snake on i'll be bad
for you
no one knows who you are without a deal
in a car it's amazing if you're not
overexposed and you look like a minion
in two tight clothes in the emoji movie
i hear you just play a hand so look i'm
gonna put it in a way you can understand
hiccup lines
in space have you ever been in a black
hole
not even light can escape
how about a swim in the milky way
complete kevin's twitter bio my name is
kevin hart and i am a piece of [ __ ] come
on
stop it that's not a piece
of
my bio and your bio i'm gonna say i'm a
piece of [ __ ] buy it would you not say
that am i buying that's the kind of
comedian you are self-deprecating like
that that they'd the world would or the
universe needed saving that that the
avengers could possibly team up with
justice league no
it's not possible
it's a whole other universe i do realize
it's a whole nother universe it would be
what would that be like it would be sad
for the justice league yeah because we'd
kick the [ __ ]
that's fine we're fine with that i love
the passion i love the friction i'm a
team player it's true
that you can win this fight are you
talking out of turn no i think we're all
talking together i normally don't do
interviews with women's unless i
fornicate with them
so you shouldn't talk anymore
unless you wanna you know you are
so old
that your publicist is a registered
nurse
you have so much fake hair
that if you commit a crime
the csi lab would probably convict some
ukrainian girl
did i hurt your feelings james on the
bright side you battle me now people
know your name
[Applause]
my talent's unshakable in your line if
you say you didn't love unbreakable
sponsors that i'm what they came to see
you'll know my name is the lord when i
lay my vengeance upon me you got your
ass kicked i'm a man twice your age then
get this [ __ ] hack off this
stage
do you look back at some of your old
lyrics given the climate of what's
happening today with women's empowerment
and be like damn that was kind of [ __ ]
up that i said no no hell no that was me
i love every [ __ ] man [ __ ] them
hoes straight up
don't say that no i'm just saying that's
me back then
your
balls stink
my balls are twice the size of yours you
have no balls
ballless
i don't care for this game
personally i don't see the i wish you
all the best i don't think the i don't
think it's going to be any different
from the previous contest
but don't worry i will take that belt
from jose and i will come back hunting
for your little [ __ ] head
okay
a little game that involves a female so
are you good with the ladies am i good
with the ladies am i good with the
ladies why don't you just ask mariah
[Applause]
how are you doing purpose yeah i'm okay
you
you're even more ugly in television than
reality
is that flatter bubbly
it's a bunch of bourbon in here
no it's um
it's flat because i thought like yo mama
oh
[Music]
my man
i'm sorry i don't know where that guy
your mom
has huge breasts
your mom is very well endowed thank you
chocolate dropper there's no stepping to
me you sang with chili peppers well
tonight you should flee he tried to win
drop your mic third try he picked the
black dude good job white guy
congrats on the new ghostbusters i'm a
fan excited to see you return as the
marshmallow man
with your swag line you think you're
sweet i feel football stadium she barely
fit in the seat
g-force more like gee he's fat the only
french word you know is buffet that's
not true i know the word uh croissant i
heard your last name used to be even
longer but you ate all the other letters
of the alphabet zack you look like a
homeless guy who's been to a soup
kitchen that specializes in ice cream
soup
it's the last stage in your training my
friend is that it
john cena
is that it with your blue eyes and your
perfect hair and your beautiful
three-piece suit your fashionable
expensive three-piece suit you look
amazing john cena do you understand me
you are amazing
he's ready
[Music]
[Music]
again well i've met a very nice man but
uh i'm sorry i don't
he hasn't seen me naked yet so
[Music]
i i can imagine oh please no
my vibrator committed suicide
next to him is a woman who's passed for
white for years
and used to be a [ __ ] in detroit
next uh to her is a wonderful tim tim
tim that's a great name for a black man
nowadays
we we discovered him in a porno film
uh because we wanted to give him a job
because he had the shortest name of any
black man in america
next sitting to him is a big black
gorilla
who was at the zoo one day
uh we fixed we fixed her hair
and and she's been acting a fool ever
since
the only difference now she cleans her
cage